طباخ السمبي دوء هكذا يقولها المصريون
ورددها من بعدهم الامريكان دونالد ترامب
يعلنها لغريمه لست في مامن من صفعات رجال
ايها العجوز بايدن الذي كان يسخر من سلفه
ترامب وهو ماثل امام القضاء يقف اليوم خلف
القطبان كمتهم ويواجه شبح العزل من
الرئاسه وكان لصالح لترامب يقول انا
انتظرك في نفس الزنزانه يا عزيز اللدود
كيف هيج دونالد ترامب الشارع الامريكي
ووضع بايدن في قفص الاتهام وما هي التهم
التي قد تطرد عجوز امريكا خارج اسوار
البيت الابيض وهل اصبح قرار عزله من منصبه
مساله وقت لا اكثر وهل سيكون دونالد ترامب
رئيس امريكا القادم لتعرف اجابه كل تلك
الاسئله تابع الفيديو للنهايه شباك ترامب
الغليظه يبدو ان ترامب لم ينسى ثاره من
عجوز امريكا فقد حرض رجاله في الكونغرس
ونقصد الجمهوريين على توجيه ضربات قاضيه
لجو بايدن وربما عزله من المنصب وانهاء
حلمه بفتره رئاسيه ثانيه لاقوى دوله في
العالم بدا الجمهوريون هجومهم الشرس
مطالبين الكونجرس بعزل بايدن عن منصبه لا
يا عزيزي ليس بسبب العمر بل ان رجال ترامب
قاموا بتوجيه تهم كبيره للعجوز الديمقراطي
والتي قد تطرده من جنه البيط الابيض الى
الابد فما هي تلك الاتهامات بايدن في مرمى
النيران يواجه الرئيس الامريكي تهاما
كفيله بالفعل بعزله من منصبه بل وربما
سجنه بعد محاكمته اشهر تلك التهم استغلال
نفوذه عندما كان نائبا لباراك اوباما في
توفير غطاء لابنه رجل الاعمال هانتر بايدن
من اجل اجراء صف قات تجاريه خارجيه في
اوكرانيا والصين وتلقيه هو وابنه هانتر
رشوه قدرها 5 ملايين دولار لكل واحد منهما
من شركه بوريسما الاوكرانيه والتي كان
هانتر عضوا في مجلس ادارتها بالاضافه الى
تلقي عائلته ومجموعه من شركائها التجاريين
نحو 20 مليون دولار من مصادر اجنبيه دون
سبب واضح وسماحه لابنه هانتر باستغلال
اسمه في صفقاته التجاريه و ودي ما يثبت
علمه بتلك الصفقات ومناقشته لها مع ابنه
عبر الهاتف وفوق كل هذا كذبه على الشعب
الامريكي عندما قال انه لا يعلم شيئا عن
صفقات ابنه وان كل شيء يتم بعيدا عن اسمه
ومنصبه كرئيس للولايات المتحده ولكن هل
نجح ترامب في الاخذ بثاره من عجوز واشنطن
المحاكمه اليوم ال8 من سبتمبر يبدا
الزلزال في تهشيم جد الحزب الديمقراطي
وتنعقد اولى جلسات مناقشه عزل جو بايدن من
منصبه انكر الديمقراطيون كل الاتهامات
الموجوده الى زعيمهم بدعوه ان كل تلك
الاتهامات لا يوجد عليها اي دليل مادي
ولكن اكد الجمهوريون ان لديهم ادله على كل
شيء فقد قال رئيس لجنه التحقيقات الجمهوري
جيمز كومر منذ يناير الماضي جمعت لجنه
الرقابه عددا كبيرا من الادله تظهر ان جو
بايدن اس استخدام المنصب العام من اجل
منافع لعائلته لقد كذب على الشعب الامريكي
حينما قال ان عائلته لم تجني المال من
الصين وكذب حتى حينما اظهرت اللجنه ان
عائلته حصلت على ملايين الدولارات من شركه
صينيه مرتبطه بالمخابرات الصينيه واضاف
قائلا هناك تسعه من افراد عائله بايدن
استفادوا من منصبه منهم بايدن نفسه ولدى
اللجنه على الاقل 20 ملفا ودليلا تظهر ان
بايدن اساء استخدام سلطته يبدو ان عائله
الرئيس الامريكي ستلقي به في الجحيم ولكن
ماذا لو فشل الجمهوريون في عزل بايدن عن
منصبه العيار اللي ما يصبش يدوش حتى اذا
لم يحكم الكونجرس بعزل بايدن اليوم يبدو
ان العملاق الاشقر ونقصد هنا ترامب سيكون
مستفيدا في كلت الحالتين فالتهمت يواجهها
عجوز واشنطن وان لم يتم اثبات صحتها
بالادله القاطعه فحتما قد اثرت على شعبيته
في الشارع الامريكي وستجعل قافله حملته
لفتره الرئاسه ثانيه تسير كال السلحفات
وهو ما ظهر اليوم ففي استطلاع للراي اجرته
صحيفه الواشنطن بوست لاظهار التاييد
الشعبي لبايدن او غريمه ترامب تراجع موقف
بايدن بشكل ملحوظ واظهر الاستطلاع تفوق
ترامب بعشر نقاط كامله ولا ننسى ان
العملاق الاشقر لا يزال متشبثا بحلم
الرئاسه والعوده الى كرسي البيت الابيض
الذهبي والسؤال الان لكم مشاهدينا هل
سيتحول بايدن ليصبح نيكسون القرن الواش
وهل سيكون دونالد ترامب هو رئيس امريكا
القادم ام ان الديمقراطيين سيكون لهم راي
اخر اخبرونا في صندوق
[موسيقى]
التعليقات
ه